okay good morning everyone
outside there guys we are starting
good morning so it's my pleasure to
introduce suvik who is a fellow here
this year and he will give us a view of
how to model sparse random graphs to see
when they have a large connected
components and things like that so with
that I don't want to take your time away
if you are online please shout your
questions uh we will not monitor them
sort of in in the chat but just you have
to speak up and ask your question
and I assume here we do the same thing
as doing all the lectures please
ask him questions as soon as you don't
understand something and I sometimes
will also ask questions whether I
understand it or not yes thank you
all right uh let's get started and
thanks for coming and let me start by
thanking Christian Jennifer Nicole and
Amin for organizing this workshop and
also asking me to give this tutorial on
uh random graphs
so I will be talking about sparse random
graphs parts means the average degree on
this type of graphs will scale not scale
the average degree will remain bound it
okay so the number of edges in the
network will scale linearly with the
network size
it turns out that the techniques to deal
with sparse random graphs are quite
different than the techniques to deal
with dense random graphs for example or
dense graphs in general as Christian
talked about
so I would like to introduce different
models of Parts random graphs and along
with it I would like to also give you
some glimpse of these techniques that we
use to deal with sparse random drugs
okay
and to release that Christian's message
if you have any questions in between
please stop me okay
so let's get started
with a few questions that we are
interested in in this Workshop how does
a disease spreading through a population
become an epidemic
foreign
networks such as Internet to break down
when does misinformation reach a large
amount of people
so at first sight this questions may
seem unrelated but there are some
commonalities here
Paul
there is an underlying Network in all
these examples which is really large
containing millions and often billions
of nodes and there is a really complex
structure that is connecting these nodes
and number two there is something
happening in these networks uh which has
drastic impact on the network right so
if we are looking at the epidemic it can
either stay content in a small region or
it can blow out or infect a lot of
people
so this type of behavior that has
drastic impact on graphs is kind of
called a phase transition phenomena
and random graphs provide quote unquote
simplified probabilistic representation
to model this type of complex systems
okay
the probabilistic grip presentation is
such that it captures
uh structural properties of the network
such as the heterogeneous degree
distribution that occur in networks also
things like community structure and also
random graphs are designed to provide
the type of phenomena that we observe in
real world for example types of behavior
like phase transition
okay
So Random graphs has both satisfies both
these purposes
so why are random graphs useful why
study them at all
well
first of all random graphs are good
graphs in some sense
General graphs are usually too messy
it's very hard to deal with that you can
always find counter examples if you are
dealing with General graphs but random
graph is kind of a way to pose
regularity properties on Networks for
example random graphs has nice property
like expansion and also Christian will
be talking about a lot of Notions of
convergence right and random graphs
usually have this convergence properties
as well okay in this sense random graphs
are good graphs first of all
and number two is often random graphs
reveal the core properties uh that are
responsible for our phenomena of
Interest
this may seem vague at first but this is
the thing we will focus on actually
the example we'll be considering is to
see how local neighborhood structure of
random graphs influence global
properties like this phase transition
emergence of large components or
distances in the graph so okay
and finally
in CS
the random graph served as a good ground
to get provable guarantees of heuristic
algorithms for example there are many NP
heart problems such as graph
partitioning and coloring and usually
when one comes up with heuristic
algorithm one tries to First verify them
on random graphs
the third theme I will not go into at
all I will stay on the second most of
the facts
okay so here is our plan today
uh today I will mainly focus on one
technique called local branching process
approximation on random graph
we will understand this technique on a
very simple probabilistic model called
Ed doshini random number which you might
have heard about already
and explore this technique and its
relation to the giant component problem
on it differential sub graph okay so
once we set up the techniques and sort
of get a sense of what are the high
level steps after that we will apply
this technique to more and more complex
models
so this part I will do in detail
the tomorrow coming up is percolation
relation to epidemics on networks as
well I'll talk about that and also if
there is time I will talk about a very
nice technique that uses stochastic
process convergence uh to deduce
properties of random graphs okay
so that's the plan
let's get started with the most
Elementary yet I would say most
fundamental model of random graph it's
the strenu random graph right
so we are given nodes say labeled 1 to n
here
and the model is simple it each Edge in
the graph appears with probability P
independently so at the end we end up
with a random sub graph of the complete
graph
throughout I will use this notation e r
NP to denote random graph on N vertices
and P is the probability
okay
now although this model is called it
this really random graph this model was
actually studied by Gilbert in 1959
mathematically and also heuristically by
solomonov and Rapoport uh in biology
in 1959 worked with a slightly different
model where usually one would choose
this ages uniformly at random instead of
keeping them independently with
probability
however uh in a sequence of like eight
papers or so on uh the they laid the
foundation of the modern random graph
Theory we know today okay so that's why
I think uh this even this random graph
model is directly called the it's the
shrine number graph model in the
literacy
okay so should I make a small obnoxious
there's a sociologist Mourinho who in
1938 was Computing probability of
isolates in basically an ER graph okay
as a corollary sociometry so there's
even older yes
it was in 1938 okay thank you
okay uh
so what are we after uh
we are looking at interesting hand
number when the network becomes really
large let's say uh we take and reduce
any random graph with n equals thousand
now
we see something is happening uh when we
go from P equals 0.5 Over N to P equals
say 2 over n
so on the picture on the left you can
see all the components are really small
they are microscopic components right
and on the right you see there is a huge
component that gobbles up most of the
vertices in the network
and there is only one large component
that doubles up most of the vertices
there are no two large components right
that's very important
so you will see actually the same
behavior or same type of pictures if you
even saw put P equals 0.9 Over N here
and P equals 1.1 over n on the right
okay you'll see kind of the same
pictures
so uh
the results we are after is
if P equals Lambda over n
then there is a phase transition around
Lambda equals one think of Lambda as the
average degree of people in the network
okay so it it is just saying that if the
average degree in the graph is less than
one then all components are small
microscopic you see this picture
and if the average degree is more than
one there is a unique giant component
there is only one giant Comfort yes
all right
average degrees n
he judges two notes it touches so if you
look at the degree of one verdict yeah
so it has a binomial many connections
right what is the binary it is binomial
n minus one b
so the expectation is n times p
n minus 1 times B okay right so P equals
Lambda over n
okay the number of edges it's Lambda
over two yeah
number expect number match is about
you will be trained if you fix the
number of edges of this XP
okay sorry never mind I'm sorry
yeah so we are trying to find component
sizes right what do we do when we try to
component the compute component sizes we
run some exploration algorithm like Brit
first search for example and when the
breadth first touch ends at that moment
we have found the component and then we
know the size of the component right
we'll do exactly same on the advert
number we do breadth first exploration
starting from say an arbitrary node node
one
okay
so uh
this is how the breadth first
exploration will look probably uh just
uh in the first step how many neighbors
will it have
I just said it will have binomial n
minus 1 Lambda over in many rivers right
so in the first step of the with
participation these many neighbors uh
will be explored how many neighbors will
be explored in the second step can
anyone tell me
how many so what is the distribution of
the number of nodes that you get in the
second step
from each node
exactly thank you so this is binomial n
minus 4 because 4 vertices have been
explored uh we have n minus four
unexplored right and we can generalize
this argument
so in general let's say s i either is
the number of vertices explode up to
time I so n minus s i is the number of
unexplored vertices then each of the
vertices at depth I will produce
binomial n minus s i and Lambda in many
new vertices in the next step
okay
so now we know how many uh
things are produced in the next step but
there is one problem when we
should
so if I look at the first vertex I agree
that this is pin I minus four Lambda
Over N but if it looks at the next one
on that same level you actually have n
minus seven because you're not allowed
to so this formula is not required
program but it's not it's only the first
one in generation either test system
let's make it precise so I say that
conditioning on whatever has happened up
to that I what is the distribution of
each of the things that what are the
distribution of them that is always by
doing n minus
please
so
there are first of all two obstacles to
analyze this process number one is we
see that this number of unexplored
vertices is depleting right over time so
there is
a depletion of vertices that makes
analyzing this process challenging and
number two is there can be conflicts
right so it can be that there are
vertices which connect to say two
vertices in the previous generation it
can happen in a graph
ICS are returning to Christian sense or
a question indeed is you are describing
this
is
then I think as Christian pointed out
it's kind of about the coupling when you
are working on but that's fine
approximately you're all the same
although you didn't describe it that way
because you are looking on here
I should be just a step yeah
whatever has been happening up to wall
uh
okay so there are two problems depletion
and conflicts uh
let's get rid of these things and so
let's consider a random process that
does not have any depletion neither does
it have a conflict right so in this case
we have binomial in Lambda n many
neighbors in the Next Generation always
uh and similarly it continues in the
next Generations as well
so the object that you see on the right
where each vertex produces binomial in
Lambda Over N many vertices in the next
step
is called a branching process we will be
using branching processes a lot in the
proof
okay but now we see a very simple fact
the fact is let NK be the number of
vertices at depth k for the industrian
exploration and n k bar is the number of
vertices for the branching process so we
see this simple fact that number of
things we have in the exploration is
less than equal to number of things we
have in the branching process okay let
me write this because I will use it a
lot
in case
yeah it is a big pen
and there is NK bar which is
the same thing
for the branching process right and we
know NK is less than equal to n k
good
[Music]
now just using this fact we can say why
the component sizes are small if Lambda
is less than one just using this simple
fact why
let's say C1 is the component size of
vertex 1.
and let's try to just compute the
expected component size of vertex 1.
well this is equal to the sum over the
things that we find in breadth first
exploration is in each of the steps so
we sum over everything and take
expectation but now using our nice fact
we can Bound in K by n k bar
the the number of things that are
produced in the branching process
so uh
we are left to calculate the expectation
of NK bar what is the number of things
we get from branching process right so
let's do a simple calculation
we will try to show for a branching
process this number is Lambda to the
power K it is decaying geometrically
so
suppose we condition on the previous
generation
right so you have in K minus 1 bar in
the previous generation and each of them
is producing binomial n Lambda over n
so this is the expectation will be 10
times Lambda Over N but we have NK
minus one bar many in the previous
generation so it is equal to
expectation expected number of things we
see in the next generation is equal to
this quantity
the expectation of n k bar equals these
things cancel Lambda times expectation
of n k minus 1 bar and now you see what
is happening we can iterate this
equation again and again to arrive at
this expectation is decaying G vertical
right
decaying like Lambda to the power k
so since Lambda less than 1 we can sum
over this and we have the expected
component size is less than equal to 1
over 1 minus Lambda
so what have you shown we have shown
that if Lambda is less than 1 then the
branching process has size o1
and therefore the expected component
sizes which is upper bounded by the size
of the branching process that is also
capital of one right
so this is showing that if Lambda is
less than 1 all the component sizes are
small of course uh in order to prove it
for all components you have to think of
Maximum right you have to get uniform
guarantees on the component sizes
so let's State this result uh so if
Lambda is less than 1 then the maximum
component size
decays like logarithmic of n so if you
divide by n it converges to this
quantity I Lambda there is no time here
that's the type
so it kind of makes sense because the
branching process protein is
exponentially right so maximum is log uh
n but ah this maximum the fields are not
really independent so one has to be
careful while doing the analysis
uh
okay I will not prove it okay I just
wanted to mention this result uh but if
you are interested in the proof
the proof uses large deviation estimates
for branching processes and
you might notice that this is actually
related to large division rate functions
right so it's the large derivation rate
function for a poisson random variables
so you can use large deviation to get
more precise estimates on the tail
probability that component size is more
than
some number t okay
okay next up
Lambda more than one
first let's again look at our branching
process what does the branching process
do
well from now we will do a
simplification instead of considering
binomial n Lambda over n prosely we will
consider poisson Lambda many protein
they are approximately same right by
limit theorem of binomial distribution
so at each step this branching process
will produce poisson Lambda from now on
instead of binomials
now there is a classical fact in
branching processes that says if Lambda
is more than one so the average number
of children produce in each generation
if that is more than one
then the branching process Will Survive
up to infinitely many generations
and this probability is positive it says
stays bounded away from zero okay
you can even calculate this probability
using this fixed Point equation
so let me just
tell you why this arises
this one minus Zeta equals to e to the
power minus Lambda Theta well
1 minus Theta Lambda is the probability
that the branching process does not
survive right
so
it the branch it's the probability that
branching process dies out but
if the branching process dies out then
all of its for all Neighbors
foreign
the branching process is not Infinity
the original branching process none of
its neighbors can survive
but now uh
let's say we have X many neighbors
so then this probability is equal to
uh let's just write the equation this is
equal to 1 minus Zeta Lambda because
each of these are also poisson branching
processes right
so and none of them will survive so 1
minus Theta Lambda to the power x right
because we have X many project
we can take the expectation of this but
X is a poisson random variable we can
calculate the probability generating
function
of python random variables and you get e
to the power minus Lambda Theta from
there
the probability
is it is a sum over or possible number
of sub trees let's say uh L that is some
of all possible the probability the cost
of Lambda is equal to l times 1 minus a
your survival probability to the power L
because all the sub trees should die
down but if you take the multiplication
no there will be one parameter extra
parameter to take the expectation
12 times them
selves
and all of them have to die out after if
you take the expectation it would be
really beautiful for pgs the evaluation
of the pgf there will be one one factor
of
course
one minus E Lambda to the L which is e
to the minus calculation
all right
so this is how you can also
the survival probability of the planting
process and if Lambda equals Lambda more
than one then there is actually always a
unique positive solution to this
equation that that corresponds to our
branching process survival problem
s
draw the function e to the minus Lambda
Z times the function one minus Lambda
subscribers
Okay so
this decade like this
right and
I can drop it correctly because yes and
so there is only one second
solution
oh so if I have one minus beta
right so theta equals 0 is 0 theta
equals zero it is one the left hand side
and
the left hand side you get this one and
on the right hand side uh
thank you questions
okay
now back to uh
so we now know that the branching
process Will Survive up to inside and
even Generations but the whole point of
the argument that we will see coming
next is the exploration the project
process is not only an upper bound to
the expression it follows uh the branch
the exploration follows the branching
process very closely so they grow
together
therefore if the branching process
survives the exploration continues for a
long time and if that happens that gives
rise to a large component okay that's
sort of the intuition
so a component is large with some
probability Zeta Lambda say
right
so in the beginning you can do even some
backup then develop calculations like
number of vertices that are in large
components is approximately M Zeta
Lambda so n Zeta Lambda is the number of
vertices that are in large components
but from this uh it's not clear how many
large components are there and also what
does large mean right so that could be
that there are two components of size in
Zeta Lambda over 2 or square root and
many components of PSI square root n but
that is not the case uh and we have this
result
so let's see I be the ith largest
component of at the near number let's
write this notation because we'll use it
foreign
so don't get it confused with c
bracket U that we saw right let's let's
see bracket V because this is the
science this is size and this is the
component size
containing the
so
this is saying that if we look at the
largest component the proportion of
vertices in the largest component is
approximately equal to Zeta Lambda and
there is only one giant component the
second largest component is small
compared to the largest component so as
I promised we'll see that a unique giant
emerges foreign
we will prove it
so the main idea is to get bounds on
moments of that component size
so we will mainly prove to lemmas the
first Lemma is concerns the proportion
of vertices
in components of size greater than equal
to l
okay so this sum if you forget about it
this sum is the total number of vertices
that are inside components
of size greater than equal to l
and the quantity on the left is just the
proportion of vertices
and I claim
this proportion is approximately equal
to our Zeta Lambda plus a smaller
correction the correction goes to 0 if
we blow n to infinity and then L to
Infinity okay if we take n and a large
we will get this so in a sense this is
the first moment of the distribution of
component sizes
good
will also show
the second moment of the component size
distribution
of large components
that converts this to Zeta Lambda
squared the square of this quantity
now I claim that the proof just follows
very easily
so
you need some more n goes to Infinity
because then error yes
[Music]
probability that x n l is more than
Epsilon
so n tends to Infinity limit L tends to
Infinity
equals 0 for all Epsilon positive that's
the reverse okay
yes
shouldn't this typically L depending on
the N like of water and structure you
don't need it no so the proof that I'll
be doing is from this book random blocks
and complex networks volume two and for
this you don't know this middle no
middle ground business at all yes I will
do that but for that you actually don't
need
for help to grow with it thanks
so the whole idea is we want to set up a
proof that will work for other random
graphs models it should not specialize
with those linear numbers uh so uh we
will try to find conditions under which
these two lemas can be verified very
easily
well now I claim that from this the
followed very easily uh why is that
let's say x i equals uh our c i over an
indicator
see I is greater than equal to l right
so the condition is just saying that sum
over x i is approximately equal to Zeta
Lambda and sum over x i square is
approximately equal to
Zeta Lambda squared
but then well approximations can be made
precise using Epsilon Delta argument so
we will not go there so that implies
sum over x i x j i not equal to J this
is a cross product terms so we can take
a square here right so we know that the
cross product terms will be
approximately zero so it cannot be that
two of the terms are positive if that is
the case then cross product won't be
zero so only one of them can be positive
and since the sum is Zeta Lambda
that one will be data Lambda so this
shows that the large component sizes
proportion of vertices in that is
approximately equal to Zeta Lambda and
the second largest component uh
has a negligible proportion
[Music]
ality is a second moment
s that you have to eventually control
all right
no uh so we'll see when we get there
what we're doing okay
so uh
this completes our proof of existence
and uniqueness of the time uh are there
any questions up to this point because
now I will dive into the proof of these
two levels
any questions
sorry to switch the argument so you take
the square of the equation in Lemma one
and say that
yes
and there is a way to conclude this
cross product
which is a separate matter not covered
by dilemmas
okay
so next uh we so wait wait
just due to this question do the lemmas
just implied or do you need another
Lemma to control the cross well I mean
you could have written this in terms of
cross products that's what exactly we
actually show uh but uh I just yeah okay
so these two levels don't quantify you
need a small incident type but not
really yeah so they they imply that
cross product comes go to zero and the
cross production is going to zero that
is something we will be verifying for it
so these two implies across products go
to zero which then implies that you have
a unique charge right
so the lemas so this is not a separate
thing these two I
think yes this wire
the mark supposed to mean
oh no I misunderstood what you said
sorry so it is enough I just don't I
don't immediately see how the so your
claim is the second level implies the
cross product yeah well the second level
implies that cross product I used it for
this argument right so actually what
turns out to be important the type load
this year in terms of like a second
moment condition that looks nice but
actually what you need to verify is this
condition the product is zero and we
will verify that condition
zero and therefore the second moment is
uh square but if you know this first
moment level then cross product is zero
is if and only with sum of squares so
that's an equivalent statement so I have
not read it in one of them
foreign
okay uh so next we will prove the two
levels but before that we need to set up
something
uh
remember we said that the whole point of
this argument would be to show that the
expiration grows together with the
branching process so the exploration is
approximately equal to the branching
process okay so let's let's set up that
tool
so we will show that NK is approximately
equal to n k bar so nkn and K Bar the
number of vertices at depth k for the
exploration and branching process
uh and this approximation
stays true until we have explored as
many vertices where s equals n to the
power a uh where a is less than 1 to be
precise uh
but it is saying as long as you have not
explored a proportion of what vertices
the positive proportion of vertices
until that the branching process and the
exploration process grows together
always
okay
okay so uh
in order to prove this approximation
remember that there were two sources of
discrepancy right the First Source was
the depletion of vertices
but we can deal with depletions quite
easily well binomial n minus s if s
equals smaller f n the approximation
that we have always on Lambda uh
many neighbors explode in each step that
Still Remains true always
okay so the depletion does not matter
too much
what about conflicts
remember conflicts are things where uh
since you argued the same generation by
generation
it's less clear to me how this depletion
works because while the first one you
sort of for the first time you know that
you use the number of purchases from the
last step if you do a whole generation
how do you know that you don't actually
that you get the task of your
exploration in your life so you need
some uniformity conditions
so just for me how do you deal with it
uh so I think that you can come up with
some uh concentration type arguments
here
because as long as s equals says model
of one then this approximation is true
uniformly but we're discussed it starts
growing the new concentration will keep
it
that because you have explored a lot of
vertices then the branching process
started explanations
uh so the expected the number of
vertices you produce in the Next
Generation less tends to consent it if
you have survived after a long
generation I will talk about it in a
moment so what he's saying is we want to
have a lot of vertices in generation t
then the generation t plus one is the
sum of many random diets are
concentrated but they're not independent
anymore and so I still don't buy your
concentration uh
yes they are not independent but the
coupling says
he's using upper coupling therefore he
has always
end up a coupling and then you use turn
off I think
both concentration this is a traditional
one uses
a due to generation a generation
so you can do the lower company right so
here I mean we will only use this fact
until s equals x square root n
foreign
so what about uh let's try to compute
the number of conflicts right
so I claim the expected number of
conflicts is
some constant times Lambda to the power
2 K Over N
now why is that let's say suppose you
are in the K minus one is Generation
until which you have explored s k minus
one many vertices so outside there will
be n minus s k minus one vertices right
and each of them are candidates of
producing a conflict
now a conflict occurs if this vertex
connects to two vertices in the previous
generation which happens with
probability Lambda Square Over N squared
so the expected number of conflicts
is less than equal to
expectation of
uh say n minus s k minus 1 times Lambda
Square Over N Square so you have taken
care of all the possibilities here and
also you have to take and take care of
all possibilities here as well so there
are at most
and K minus 1 squared choices in the
previous generation
okay
well we can do a few more steps let's
replace upper bound this by n so we get
Lambda Square Over N expectation of NK
minus 1 square
again as we did the expectation
calculation we can do the expectation
calculation okay so let me do another
step so this is less than equal to
Lambda Square over n
bar Square branching process but for the
branching process we can compute moments
iteratively right we just did the
calculation for expectation you can do
the similar thing uh for the square as
well the calculation becomes complicated
so I will not do it
okay
so but if you do the calculation you
will see that expectation of n k minus 1
bar squared is like Lambda to the power
so K minus 1. okay
so this fact holds
so uh we will now use this fact to
conclude two things that will be
important in the proof of the two levels
that we have
the first thing is if K is a large but
constant quantity so it does not grow
within but K is largely
oh
it should be 10 seconds I don't know if
I plug in this together then I will have
an alarm that 2K Over N Square where am
I wrong now no so you have this end
right we did in the last quantity
expectation of n Bar Square you just
claim that this is longer two to the K
minus one third okay thank you for the
text this is this goes in Lambda thank
you so much that was the mistake
you don't really need those conflicts
right because you can just do the
classical computer science that first
the red first search right so you just
take a guy from the queue expand to the
new verses and then it takes another one
expense on you just don't go like layer
by layer not just go vertex by vertex
and then uh you just keep going until
you discover say end to two parts versus
um and then you have lower bounded is
just independent random variables and
they're all the same distribution
um
so you need an upper bound you need a
lower bound yes I am trying to make that
available I think there's no need for
confidence
but then I think he's preparing to show
Cycles I think yeah
so the whole point that I I will be
trying to make is that if you have
locally weekly converted the and then
you have another additional condition
then you have this concentration object
but local we convert this to a branching
process for that you need to control
conflicts
so if a is the large constant that the
expected number of conflict is zero uh
which says the exploration is exactly
equal to the branching process with
probability tending to one right we can
find a coupling such that the
exploration would stay exactly same as
the branching process up to say a finite
number of generations
okay
that's the fact one that we'll be using
it's not accept on the inside
and exactly but then they have with
probability approximately worked one
here you have
foreign
and therefore the expected number of
conflicts is constant times n to the
power to a minus 1.
on the other hand we know something
about branching processes
so we know that the branching process
may die out but when it survives
conditioned on its survival uh
let's say branching process survives to
an odd generation where R is large
condition on that fact the further
growth of the branching process will be
exponential in Lambda well
used to be number of vertices now we are
talking about fraction of the vertices
which is it because
okay uh so condition on the fact that we
have explored a lot condition on that uh
our branching process growth exponential
in land so and Lambda to the power k for
such choices of K is 10 to the power
yeah
so what is happening uh we can compare
now these two right
now if a is less than one then a to the
power 2 A minus well 2A minus 1 is less
than a if a is less than one so the
number of conflicts is a smaller order
than
the number of things you see in the
branching process so therefore
the number of conflicts is small of n k
bar with hydraulic
foreign
so the neighborhoods of the exploration
process grows exponentially in Lambda
right that the uh that's the main thing
okay so too many computations but the
thing that I want you to remember from
this slide is when we know that the
exploration process is surviving the
condition on the fact that it has
survived for a long time already
condition on that after that the growth
of the exploration process becomes
exponential so what do you mean by long
so that means you have there is an
iterated limit here
so this is
so you have to do it he's doing a lot of
conditioning conditioning on good event
conditioning of the other good events
no but you can't say condition on having
to survive for the long end log means
okay let me make it precise so there
exist an R
that depends on l
so uh okay for any given Epsilon there
is a
so for any given Epsilon we can choose
this
oh wait
I think that's a bit of it okay so for
any given L uh do we know that the
component size will be greater than
equal to 10 right if that even happens I
want to conclude that the exploration
process survives up to some generation
part where R depends on l and if n goes
to Infinity then R will also will
significant as a function of n
that's whatever
okay but you always have an end to
itself yeah we said it will send you
have to send them before
okay now that's why you mean exponential
in K at the very end right
exponential
yeah exponential in Lambda so it grows
uh like Lambda to the body 4K so it's K
large enough okay like people just take
her a fixed number or growing
so okay
is if we take a like login then we have
this
oh but it was you just all said you
didn't have
uh we will again use that so it will
come up uh you will see when it comes up
so there is a two neighborhood argument
so for
you will see but
lambdeeper is average degrees
so what is exponential in average I mean
I think the branching process expands
exponentially a number of steps
but it it didn't okay so the conclusion
is here like into the part K is
approximately equal to Lambda to the
power of K right that's what I want to
do yeah
with high probability well it will
probably be uh which is becoming
going which is going to zero yeah I
guess I'm just saying nothing is an
exponential function of average it's an
exponential you know yes yes
the function 2 to the K is exponential
in case
well we have now set up these two
ingredients now let's prove the next two
lemons
well
to prove uh
this one picture
so each video uh
well it I mean again it becomes like if
you even take like when the branching
process or the exploration has become of
size login then also if if you let this
go with him then this approximation you
will tell you right so because then you
will know that already you have survived
up to a long time
and if you survive up to a long day
after that the concentration will be
it doesn't depend on
them
it does not depend on any other things
yeah
well uh
we want to do this uh I will just show
you this approximation volts in
expectation I will not do the variance
configuration okay uh
because it is significantly more
involved so I'll try to show this in
expectation
this proportion of vertices in
components in large components is
approximately Theta Lambda
okay let's first rewrite this proportion
let U be a Vertex that is uniformly
chosen from the graph and U is
independent
U is independent of the graph
then the proportion of vertices in large
components is exactly the probability
that this uniformly chosen vertex will
land in one of the component that has
size at least l
okay
it's just uniform distribution property
done nothing funny here
and if U Falls in a component of size
greater than equal to L that means
component size of U is greater than
equal to l
now in expectation therefore we have to
calculate this probability the component
size of U is greater than equal to l
but now we know something
so from previous slide we know the
exploration process starting from any
vertex say U
would be exactly following the branching
process with probability tending to 1.
so
uh the probability that the component
size is greater than equal to l is
approximately equal to probably that the
bunching process is greater than equal
to l right because these two random
variables are growing together
they're exactly same with probability
tending to 1. and if we take L to be
large enough
this is approximately the probability
that the branching process survives
subject to your condition on the fact
that exploration
uh
ran a long time enough so there is a
little bit of competition going on
behind the scenes No
if I want to make it turn this heuristic
into proof I need this conditional
probability because you said exploration
of you it's important to process subject
to
process runs long time enough
[Music]
well this probability is also going to 1
as you take intestine related
but you are completely like uh there are
things that are going on behind the
scene is precise
okay so we have arrived and the fact
that if you take the expectation of this
quantity that is approximately equal to
Beta Lambda
foreign
in the whole proof the only non-trivial
step was this step right whether we can
approximate this event by the
probability that the branching process
is greater than equal to n that was the
only non-trivial step so if we were to
have another random graph model say uh
where we can verify this property for
that we can prove this level right the
proof is very general
because we actually need concentration
but there are some tricks that you can
you for example you can say that the
variance number this is zero by just
looking at locals
because uh well this thing is exactly
the same as 1 minus uh
is less than
right then you can compute the handles
as long as L is fixed
yeah so you can then take that
okay so the important fact here is the
local neighborhood starting from U is
approximately a branching process uh
with probability tending to one
okay
so this is our key fact number one that
implies the convergence of the roof of
first Lemma
so this whole theory of approximating
local neighborhoods of graphs uh by some
other object in this case it is the
branching process is called the local
weak converges that I think Christian
will be talking about right uh
but what this this Lemma is just a
consequence of the fact that uh
the hit those 20 random graphs convert
this locally weekly to uh
a branching process with high
probability
okay
so far so good let's get to the second
Lemma
uh
so we can take the squares in the both
sides by the previous Lemma we know that
Zeta Lambda squared is the square of
this quantity right
and we can expand out the square and the
first term is exactly what we have here
so the second term has to go to zero
right
now we can again use the same uniform
random variable trick but in this case
we have two Ci's here and we have a
divided by N squared here so we will
take two uniform random variables now
so we take two uniform random variables
and we again use the same trick to show
that the second term is equal to the
probability that component size of U1 is
greater than equal to l component size
of u 2 is greater than equal to l and
there is a funny notation here U1 is not
equal to U2 U1 is not leading to U2 so
this means
uh U1 and U2 are not in same component
actually exploring your neighbor you
will stop perhaps when I see I flow from
U1 I see already L 36 then I think I
will stop and then I will explore you
too isn't it hard to do it's not the
complete component complete component
potentially will be in a single largest
component eventually if I see all the
component but I think you're doing
really partial exposure I'm just saying
that but this is still not for Shell
exploration The Next Step I will
simplify this event by a partial
exploration
using this motivation if they are not
using the same component
in the end of the life and we know that
posteriorly there is a unique largest
component most of this large component
will be more will be eventually one
component right yes exactly whatever the
argument you use yeah
yeah it's a kind of uh not rigorous but
it doesn't matter which one is this is
the same component in what sense not in
the same components are exactly the same
so this is
just says
it's just a definition yeah it's just
anything right
so how to calculate this event that's
the complete disappeared but let's say
it's the definition U1 and U2 is not
needing to each other
so students are not interested
conformation yeah they are not in the
same component these two components do
not intersect
so it is enough to show that probability
the U1 better than Google and CO2
greater than equal to 12. and U1 and U2
are not in the same component this
probability
goes to see
in the 18-day limit of course but what
this is saying is that if we have two
large components then two large
components cannot stay in different
couple they should intersect they have
to intercept okay
so uh
to show that our event the probability
goes to zero it suffices to show that
probability U1 does not and U2 are not
in same components conditioned on CU 1
greater than equal to l
and condition on c u 2 greater than
equal to l is approximately zero
conditioned on we have two large
components uh the components should
intersect
but now
unfortunately having conditioning on
this event is quite hard but instead we
will change this event a bit by a
different event
that leads us to use our exploration
process the tools that we develop for
exploration process right
so we will replace the conditioning
event by this event
let's understand it Delta R U1 is the
number of vertices you have
at depth R in the exploration process in
each of the exploration from U1 and U2
okay
now I claim that I can replace this
conditioning event by the given that the
boundary from after exploding from U1
and U2 this both of these boundaries are
non-zero
okay so the exploration has survived up
to uh step r
now
R is not growing
so uh
log l yeah
but R is not going with n r is a
function
so the basic idea is that if the
exploration process is growing right uh
if we know that the component size is
more than equal to Del that means the
expiration process would survive up to a
long time and vice versa if the
expression processor values up to a long
time then uh we know component facts is
greater than equal to l
it's property of we can do it for
poisson very easily
okay
so it is enough to condition on the
second event but when we condition on
the second level we see something
interesting happening
the advantage of conditioning on this
event is that now we don't have to
condition on the rest of the graph right
so we sort of this part of the graph in
between is completely unexplored so
starting from these two boundaries we
can keep on growing the two
neighborhoods
let's do it precisely next more
precisely next time uh so condition on
the two boundaries to be non-empty
and our R is large because L is large
then recall that we made this
observation in words
after the expiration process survives up
to our generation since R is large after
that the further growth of this
expression process would become
exponential
right
now the idea is from these boundaries we
start growing the two neighborhoods
in both sides so we grow the first
neighborhood of U1 up to step say K1 but
K1 is chosen such that remember that nk1
is approximately equal to Lambda to the
power K1 so K 1 is chosen in such a way
that uh
the boundary size is larger than square
root n so after K1 in this side we have
larger than square root and many
vertices we can play the same game on
the right hand side
and after that grow the second
neighborhood and grow it up to U2 until
this boundary size becomes a for the
square rooted
now I claim that after I have done that
it must be that they intersect
why is that
well the probability that there is no
Edge between the boundaries is 1 minus
Lambda Over N times all possible choices
director of my confidence
oh my gosh
you know for example now your problem is
actually that the first neighborhood
what you have brought it up to the
boundary of science fair of the fan you
can't grow the second one up to that
side yeah yeah this is again so yes yes
so the thing is that if you have to take
like large Concepts and then the if the
constants become like this probability
kind of tickets so that's uh like I
remember this it simplifies
okay
so you have to take another minute
to make it completely analytical
business
but the rough idea is this so you grow
the two neighborhoods up to size square
root 10 and after some time they will
intersect when these two neighborhoods
have grown to size square rooted then
these two neighborhoods have to
intercept that's sort of the idea
okay ah a lot of things lot of patience
but the main takeaway that you can have
from this slide is uh even if you don't
follow this iterated limit and this kind
of things is that if there are two large
components
then the exploration process would
survive up to a long time we know that
from both of the vertices U1 and U2 and
if they satisfies up to a long time
condition on that we can grow the
neighborhood further after a long time
the exponential growth rate kicks in and
when the exponential growth rate kicks
in we can grow these two neighborhoods
up to sine square root l and when they
become large enough like square root F
at that point they intersect therefore
probability that they don't intercept
that probability goes to C
again n tends to Infinity R tends to
Infinity
so that's sort of the takeaway from this
slide
coming back to the proof of the second
Lema
we first reduce the proof of the first
Lemma to the proof of this equation
which says that if we have two large
components then the cannot be in the
same component they have to be in
different components
so they have to be in the same component
they are in the different components
with probability tending to zero right
so this is the first condition we
simplified
and the second one is well dealing with
this isn't was difficult so we
condition on the art neighborhood where
R was large and after that we started
growing the two Networks
so
probability
well you are taking two limits right
which is simple so you can do so you
have you want to bump the permission
probability you apply the marketing
so the approximation you you effectively
when you went from upset to here you
Sumter what you wanted to and you use
the linearity of expectations and you
can't do that if you wanted to show that
the whole thing
so either you have to control the force
mode if you need some other argument by
this was an expectation of it because
you subbed over you want to do yes but
if you want to show that something is
going to zero itself that's expectation
we don't show this year
right so uh what have we found uh we
have been able to complete the proof of
this lemaker
but the important fact was this again
this fact uh two components two large
components cannot be desired so again if
you have another random graph model
where you have this property
that two large components cannot be
disjoint
then
I mean modulus some technical conditions
it can be shown that uh
there is a unique giant component right
so in fact I will mention uh a result in
the next slide almost
like two large components and there is
either no loss component or only one but
there can be cases right where you have
like two completely details you are
going graphs in two digit mode Etc in
those cases you can have two large
numbers
Taurus but very thin
very thin one like a ring then uh there
might be potential if you start from the
anti-portal points there might be some
some two very big components of linear
order but they not they are not
connected yeah
so um
largely only means yeah it means it
doesn't mean
it is
well if you want to about this
probability by Epsilon large means that
there exists
probability
can I ask a question about which is Fact
Two if I just turn my C in uh
differently perhaps the same thing same
coin different face or tail can you then
show that
there is connection probability so U1 is
connected to U2 the INF is uh strictly
bounded away from some constant can you
show such a thing these components are
at large so I I give you that okay you
want and you too they lie in a large
component large bounded by this cost
number l
I want to know that what is the links of
the connection probability between U1 U2
this is strictly bounded away from some
constant
then this gives a uniqueness for free of
charge perhaps what I'm saying instead
of going through all this yeah
[Music]
summer school and this whole month gave
you a very excellent truth about this
population on finite transitive perhaps
the transitive brush and somehow it
seems like it's related to that height
so I'm just a wonderful
I have such a kind of a
corresponding
[Music]
okay you know what I'm saying if there
is a
large
but if you guarantee that there is
connection probabilities always bounded
away from Casa Lambda
hello we can turn this around so he
actually
but I'm talking about nothing but um
right yeah the expectation tends to zero
to the probability
um
so are you sort of done with your
lecture
well I can't say about it
I still have 10 minutes so let's with
someone else uh we considered the
supersetical case right foreign
and the second largest is going to zero
and there were two main ingredients just
to remind you the first one is local
neighborhood approximation uh local
neighborhood of random vertex for the
branching process with high probability
and therefore branches survive is if C
is large
and we had this nice property that if
two components are larger than L then
they must intersect right so if we any
for any random graphs if we can verify
these two concrete quantities
then uh you can prove this type of
result
and we showed this by growing two
neighborhoods and they must intersect
when neighborhoods become large enough
right of order square root X
right
so I would refer you to this paper by
Brandon hofstad uh again if you so this
paper actually proves that if you have a
general sequence of graphs that converts
locally weekly to some other infinite
graph and this condition is satisfied
then you always have this theorem okay
sure
[Music]
regime when Lambda is smaller than when
the largest component of your scale by
log n you have this wonderful formula
coming from you know
can you say something here as well c2e
if we're normalized by log n then it
converges to Delta no okay it says
so that is completely a property of
course of descriptions
foreign
[Music]
so you know exactly the size of the
second largest component
so that that happens yes yes in the
industry it is true right the city if
you did not follow this proof you can
find different groups like the one you
are saying you can indeed to conclude
this is blocking
but for General graph now
what about normally Okay so
but I think morally
he knows s it
um Extinction
[Music]
then it details exponential
any destruction I mean universe is
written so you have a power law
distribution for Offspring if you
condition on
so
yeah exactly for random numbers so what
I said here is uh if you have General
locally with you converted graph it is
not true that the conversion launching
processes right but in that case also
this proof Force this is a very general
result
not only for random graphs
all right I seem to have five minutes
uh
let me quickly tell you about uh another
useful application of the technique that
we learned but uh in the context of
typical distances in Industry we will
use uh similar similar ideas uh but be
quick about the proof right so typical
distance is what you did uh it is a
graph distance between two uniform
resource and vertices so you take two
vertices you have an U2 you look at the
shortest path and how many edges are
there in between
then in Lambda more than one case you
have that the distance is scale like
login distances uh divided by login uh
convert this into probability one
and again that proves a user this
neighborhood growth idea right uh
if we so we can again use the same
neighborhood growth idea we can grow the
two neighborhoods and we saw that uh
conflicts are small and uh they have
disjoint boundaries until their size is
square root n so until their size have
become square rooted this boundary is
agreement disjoint so there is no
shortest path between you and and U2 but
at half login uh the shortest path is
created right so the shortest path will
be created when these two neighborhoods
intersect for the first time and that
happens when you take k equals log n
plus something okay
so if you take k equals login plus
something half log n plus something then
these two neighborhoods will again
intersect
uh so and we will find the shortest path
so what I'm saying here is the distance
between U1 and U2 is the size of the
boundaries of the two neighborhoods that
we have drawn
plus a small correction
right
and therefore the distance is
approximately equal to because this was
only a lower
yes
uh so I have said that they will
intersect right after this step so that
gives enough
so lower bound is what the the fact that
they do not intersect
an upper bound is they will intersect
all right I think this is a good place
to uh stop next day I will tell you
about more random graph models and apply
this technique that we have learned okay
uh yeah please let me know if you have
questions
sorry
to the worst case distance not that you
want you to are uniformly chosen but
that is in that case what it happens is
that in the giant component there are
some hanging trees as well then we have
like some critical
uh subcritical trees so you have to take
the back of their distance
so the diameter is not login but
there is a constant additive constant in
front of us
the one plus thumbnail where mu is
actually the uh
not survive
since this is pretty complicated yeah
just wondering because we know it's that
is it really low yeah
what I want you to ask is because we are
turning some
instead of the very much combinatorial
counting argument which you usually do
because the problem is still putting the
things in a more General box and it
seems to be very very nice so that's why
I'm asking if you want to have such an
external quantity whether you have also
a kind of results using max if you know
the sun uniformity is there any trick to
have a maximum thing using other
probability tricks that's that's all
right what I want to know so in
probabilistic rates uh in terms of
probabilistic traits what you have to
use is there can be hanging some
critical increase that is not taken care
of in typical distancing and that what
is the distances in subcritical skills
so you have to add that yeah
you already know it's kind of posterity
right because we know how the giant
component looks like
you know two poor and trees whatever so
it's kind of without knowing that such
an intuition would not work that's why
I'm asking is there any more high level
probabilistic argument I do know
something about
the uniform thing if I choose like a
random walk if I start from a uniform
vertex then uh mixing time will be
something but if I look at the worst
case mixing time from anywhere the worst
case can be much larger
Universe are kind of a nice animal
I do not know about anything
yeah thank you thank you but you can
actually get diameters for random number
of models like configuration model or uh
say of course
and in that case what happens if you get
this additive concept that comes from
some critical branching processes
because they can be attached to the
giant component they are there
actually
there's some general results that can
look at the largest giant component so
what is the general model how generator
so it is very general so it says that uh
if you have a locally weekly convergent
sequence of graphs uh and The Zeta
Lambda is the probability that this
graph is infinity
foreign
then
with this local weak convergence and
this additional condition you can show
this property
there is
that cover rather than regular graph
yeah
so there's a big one
okay yeah but you still have not
verified this one
I mean yeah you can actually verify this
condition for configuration models no
yeah again argument is a bit complicated
you can do it
okay
um I simply
it's a fabric so let's break up to the
left that will have different topics
every evidence